du hast ganz viele wünsche und möchtest
dir ganz tolle sachen kaufen
tja ohne geld wird das nichts aber wie
komme ich an geld probiere jetzt
arbeiten aber was ist das das prinzip
von arbeiten ist ganz einfach du tust
dinge für eine firma die bezahlte ich
dafür
und wo kann ich dieses arbeiten machen
einfach überall
du kannst zum beispiel einen ferienjob
annehmen einen ferienjob oder du
arbeitest das ganze jahr über einfach
neben seiner schulzeit oder während
eines semesters hält man einen nebenjob
du trottel
nein jetzt mal im ernst es gibt viele
dinge die man haben möchte und da eltern
ein ja nicht immer alles kaufen können
was man sich wünscht muss man irgendwie
anders an geld herankommen
seit ich 14 bin habe ich schon immer
irgendwelche jobs gemacht und mir
einfach meine freizeit auch bezahlen zu
können und ich finde dass es eigentlich
nur finanziell hilft man während auch
mit menschen umzugehen und was es heißt
wenn man das selbst erreicht hat
geschenke sind toll aber wenn du dir
etwas mit deinem eigenen verdienten geld
kaufen kannst ist ein echt gutes gefühl
also was kann man machen wenn man ein
schüler oder student ist es gibt zum
beispiel ferienjobs die duh ferien
machen kannst oder minijobs die gesetz
ganze jahr über machen kannst und es
gibt noch so unregelmäßige sachen wie
zum beispiel messe jobs als jugendlicher
gibt's bei ferienjobs einiges zu
beachten
du musst mindestens 14 jahre alt sein du
darfst nicht mehr als vier wochen oder
20 tage im jahr arbeiten täglich darf
seine arbeitszeit nicht mehr als acht
stunden haben und in der woche nicht
mehr als 40 stunden und zwischen den
einzelnen schichten muss mindestens
immer zwölf stunden pausen sein wenn man
18 ist dann sieht das alles schon ein
bisschen lockerer aus trotzdem sollte
man sich nicht ausbeuten lassen und
jetzt schluss mit dem trockenen teil
kommen wir zum spaß
jobs gibt es eigentlich überall entweder
den klassischen weg gehst in die stadt
und schaust auch der eismann deines
vertrauens oder das schwimmbad um die
ecke eine stelle anzubieten haben oder
den google ist es einfach es gibt viele
anzeigen die auf spezielle schüler oder
student besuchen
aber passt auf wenn es gibt auch da
viele betrüger die das ausnutzen wollen
haye wird so schnell und geld
herankommen nichts dafür tun dann
unterschreibe hier
und wenn uns 100 euro gegeben hast geht
es schon los ja wirklich solche angebote
als ich eine kleine wanne war habe ich
zum beispiel zeitung ausgetragen oder
wenn mit hunden raus gegangen
ab und zu dürftig auch beim nachbarn
babysitten dazu zwar keinen stress oder
keine verträge aber auch sehr
unregelmäßige geldeinnahmen und wenn man
dann 16 ist ob man im richtigen
geschäften arbeiten sei es im supermarkt
oder modegeschäft im es beim bäcker
eigentlich so wie immer sehr viele
geschäfte jemanden der nebenbei arbeiten
möchte und das ist gut für beide seiten
die geschäfte müssen nicht nur
festangestellte einsetzen und schüler
und studenten können ihr konto
aufbessern
was man dazu wissen muss ein minijob
geht bis 450 euro im monat in der regel
steuerfrei
mit einem nebenjob kannst du bis zu 8000
354 euro verdienen ohne steuern zahlen
zu müssen
der mindestlohn von 8 euro 50 ist dabei
eine echt gute sache allerdings kriegt
man den erst ab 18
ich weiß nur dass ich einmal beim
bewerbungsgespräch war wo mir das
geschäft fünf euro 40 die stunde
angeboten hat und da sollte man auch
wirklich aufpassen denn auch hier gibt
es viele menschen die das ausnutzen
wollen dass jemand gerne arbeiten möchte
so was wie traumjob von zu hause oder
ganz schnell an geld ran kommen heißt
eigentlich immer gib uns dein geld und
wir tun so als ob du später was davon
hast
ich mag euch meinen link dazu in der
infobox da könnt ihr gute beispiele für
falsche anzeigen sehen
ich bin diesen falschen anzeigen
eigentlich mehr damit aus dem weg
gegangen dass ich von geschäft zu
geschäft gelaufen bin und die leute
direkt angesprochen habe das hat zum
vorteil dass du den chef direkt
ansprechen kannst und die nicht über
irgendwelche seiten also über
irgendwelche seiten in kontakt aufnimmt
und an alle die da draußen schon mal
einen nebenjob einen nebenjob einen mini
job gemacht haben vielleicht könnt ihr
ja mal eure erfahrung in die kommentare
schreiben
dass andere sich auch daran orientieren
können und ich möchte bitte nicht nur
hören
mein chef von scheiße denn ich weiß ist
da draußen auch gute jobs also los
schreibt zeigen da unten
das war es wieder von mir für diese
woche und ich wünsche euch ganz ganz
ganz viel geld und ein schönes leben